want to actually advocate for men and
show them that we're not all like that
yeah no it's it's interesting
um I don't is it so in the U.S
um I know if someone gets divorced and
they have a kid with a girl in certain
States they have to pay 25 of their
after-tax income per kid
um I don't think it's as bad here no no
is it similar or no I don't think it's
though it can be similar but I think
what the thing is I think the US is a
bit more Cutthroat yeah yeah in terms of
English law we go by Case by case and
there's more of a
there's a lot more fairness I think from
what I've seen so far which is good
because I mean in America you have
community property states which are just
like completely just cut the house the
Assets in the middle who cares what
happened in the case yeah and that
that's horrible because some cases are
really unique and they deserve attention
but then you have Equity distribution
states in America some some states and
uh which is what you expect of the Lord
to look at every single case and uh yeah
the the one that I was involved in was
an equitable distribution state
so the fact is the ex-wife actually
didn't fulfill the factors
um so that actually what gained like
that worked in favor of my client what
has fulfill the factors mean so the
statutory factors for he was in the
state of Colorado and in the state of
Colorado you have statutory factors for
example you know I don't know how how
people are going to take this but it is
the factors for example if she wants 50
she will basically get whatever
percentage from the assets if we can uh
like compensate compensating for her
contribution to the marriage if she took
care of children there's a percentage
she gave up things like home making
as opposed to his 50 does that make
sense yeah so she can it could be 70 you
know 20
yeah like that no that's that's really
cool that's really interesting when I
found out about the state I was like
that's brilliant yeah and community
property States oh really scary like
California is
that's that's the one where I heard this
guy was like going to retire and then he
couldn't retire because he his wife left
him and took the kid to Japan
yeah and like it it's crazy because I
guess in some states like the courts are
separate like the courts for like child
support and the divorce courts so when
he went to child support like to get
child support they would just say oh you
weren't in the kid's life the last six
months but they don't put in the fact
that like she wasn't letting him be yeah
so it's kind of it's very
um especially in the US here I looked up
I I think they get like 13 to like 20
ish per kid if that was correct right is
that yeah I don't know if that's it's
not as Cutthroat I think as the US from
what I learned but that's generally but
again they look at each and every case
which is important because we can't we
can't say it's definitely gonna go this
way differently right right okay sorry
that was just interesting that's why I
asked okay
um so I was gonna say on on a slightly
slightly on a tangent but similar topic
uh fun fact like one of my friends who
studied in law in the UK I actually
asked him about the topic of
um you know like prenups and I said like
you know it must be a good idea right
you're safeguarding yourself you're
safeguarding each person then you feel
like it's a little bit more comfortable
going into the relationship and I said
like surely that's like a good way to go
you know in a trusting way and he was
like actually like there are loopholes
just because you have a prenup does not
mean you are going to get away you know
without compensation so
um it might work a little bit better in
America but let's say in the rest of the
world that's that's not the case and
he's like if you're smart especially
like people who have wealth from their
family old family
um they actually like when their kids
get married they actually like they
don't put things or assets under their
children's name for a reason because if
the woman tries to divorce the man and
try to get the assets they can't because
it's under the entire family rather than
under an individual so he was saying
like there are ways
that you can so you can put your
sister's name you can get your brother
so it's like you know like it's it's
it's not yours it's it's the family and
so if that's the way that something's
named then you that that you can kind of
get away with it but you cannot just say
well I've got prenup so this is pre yeah
and that's scary that's scares me it's
and it's hard because I'm very
pro-marriage in like a family sense but
I understand like why guys don't want to
get married you know it like makes sense
because I'm like if I have if I could
possibly lose this much of my assets I
wouldn't want to get married either if
the like the roles were reversed and
what's more terrifying is that you don't
even have to get married to get the same
treatment that's the you can't even
cohabit because it's horrible you kind
of it's like it's like they legally
twist their arm like they say well you
know what no then let's not get married
and they say ah but if you live with her
for this many years it's like
I actually I don't know if anyone is
Canadian in the audience who might know
but actually I heard that in Canada
maybe I might be making this up but I
thought I heard that it doesn't you
don't even have to be married if you've
been living with your partner for a
certain amount of years that
automatically that person can try and
get money from you I mean I don't I
don't know I don't know I think that's I
think they're that's true but I might be
wrong so if anyone if I'm wrong please
correct me
okay I'm sorry sorry no no it was it's
interesting that's okay
um so today we're talking about is the
bar set low for men so the reason
um that I thought of this was because I
was like scrolling through my Tick Tock
and there's this trend going around
where it's like girls will say well the
bar is so low for men and then you know
explain and so I wanted to show you guys
a video-ish if you want to pull it up
um
[Music]
it's basically a compilation of girls
when they talk about
you know how how low the bar is because
you know between men and women
apparently
you know women are the ones with the low
standards you know men just have the
high standings yeah yeah wait so I I see
so so the girls are saying on social
media that they have low standards for
men is that what they're trying to say
sort of you'll see it a second I'm so
confused for this one
so I guess while we're waiting to
represent what we're waiting for ish to
set this up um who do you guys think has
higher standards men or women just off
the bat
women official women women 100 from a
biological standpoint definitely the
girls women
women yeah see this it's interesting
because everyone genuinely agrees here I
could tell I was like this group's gonna
be based
um I think like it's I think it's
important that like we obviously will be
talking about the general trends of
things but then obviously there is
they're outliers right so
um from a biological standpoint it makes
sense that the girls more picky because
you get pregnant you're going to be nine
months your body's gonna get distorted
by the way it's yeah you're never going
to be the same and it's not fun giving
birth so to subject yourself you you
really have to you know really pick
someone whereas a guy you almost can
forget about it that's why women once
when when they um when they ask
questions like why can't we do the same
things as men why can't we sleep around
the same as men the answer is right
there you can get pregnant it's not
complicated I hate that comparison women
go off in the tension but you can do
this so we can do this you clearly can't
because not just that it's also a pair
bonding too like you know if you want to